et moi j' bon là les vieux et là les
vieux se sont
régalés c'est la chanson préférée c'est
la chanson préférée de ma mère qui veut
stall faire un jeu qui veut stall je
vais donc faire un jeu je vais donc
faire un jeu je vais donc faire un jeu
ché un jeu qui consiste en quoi un jeu
que je vais inventer
incessamment les Chéries c'est très bien
c'est un jeu le voilà comment ça va toi
ça va
bien
génial merci non je te jure je peux plus
te
supporter Mme pas dit
[Applaudissements]
unot les Chéries qui veut stball marche
sur la tête je l'offre également à un
téléspectateur puisqu'il y aura un
deuxième regardez ah ouais c'est comme
des bateaux il y en a toujours un
derrière l'autre ah ouais frin regardez
j' offre un autre sur Twitter hstall s W
B a del pe les faire parler encore les
Chéries regardez-les regard ils sont là
trs mign et je vais offrir quelqu'un va
repartir avec ça c'est pas évident pour
le métro c'est toujours
sympa non mais trop c'est toujours sympa
et sur Twitter on tirera quelqu'un au
sort qui partira avec cet animal le jeu
est simple je
vais confectionner un jeu là dans les
prochaines
secondes
qui va consister à faire gagner cet
animal on fait les chiffres ouais les
chiffres c'est bien les chiffres mais
c'est pas pour vous c'est pour le croyez
vraiment que je vais compter 250
personnes faut faire les boules j'aime
bien les boules c'est très simple les
gars les boules on les a pas donc c'est
très simple écoutez-moi bien je vais je
vais procéder je vais faire un jeu de
télépathie ah la vache c'est très simple
une belle Arna je vais appeler mon fils
ah ah ho ok je vais dire droite gauche 1
de VO il va choisir quelqu'un comme ça
en public il ne sait pas ce que je fais
oui mais nous non plus il sait pas je
vais appeler mon fils lino ou bien si
vous voulez j'appelle même quelqu'un
d'autre si vous voulez j'appelle même
quelqu'un de mon répertoire au hasard
delinn ou n'importe qui delphinnot tu as
raison Jean-Pierre fou je Jere
fouppre j'appelle jeierre fou ro des je
j'appelle Jean-Pierre fouca c'est parti
il n'est pas au courant bien entendu
Jean-Pierre attention Cyril Hanouna
Anouna Cyril va t'appeler va te
contacter Jean-Pierre fouc
102 ans de
carrière mon animateur préféré c'est mon
bébé je l'appelle Jean-Pierre foucot qui
doit préparer les Miss France il doit
être en train de boire un verre avec
missakiten et qui sait qui va le faire
chier
ramouna alors en tout cas je suis très
inquiet parce que allô Jean-Pierre oui
bonjour monsieur cyil Anouna Cyr comment
me
ditesvous ramouna Cyr ramouna
ah ça me dit quelque chose comment
Jean-Pierre je suis en direct donc ne me
dis ne me dis pas de la sanité comme tu
me dis quand on se parle d'habitude hors
r bien entendu déjà je voulais te dire
que je t'embrassais très fort et que tu
me manquais tu le sais je t'ai écris la
semaine dernièreilleurs pour te le dire
tu tu m'as écrit je l'ai lu ça m'a
profondément touché et depuis je je
reste quoi tellement je suis abassourdi
par cette information que tu m'as
communiqué je sais et je sais queon va
bientôt déjeuner ensemble n'amène rien
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau
ça franchement ça me surprend oui
vraiment et oui j'ai ché et oui j'ai
ché Jean-Pierre je t'explique un peu je
devais improviser un jeu et tout le
monde m'a dit il faut appeler le roi du
jeu Jean-Pierre foucco j'ai dit bah
voilà donc Jean-Pierre c'est très simple
je vais te demander juste des trucs et
tu me dis tu réponds juste à mes
questions si je te dis droite ou gauche
droite gauche tu me dis droite donc donc
le gagnant est ici pour faire gagner
quelqu'un le gagnant est à droite ce cé
on va dire 1 2 3 les Rangers si je te
dis 1 2 ou 3 tu me dis quoi 3 3 donc
c'est
ici maintenant tu vas me choisir en haut
un chiffre de 1 à 10
11 pas
mal de de 1 à 10 al non 8 8 c'est donc
ben voilà vous faites 1 2 3 4 5 c'est
toi premier finaliste c'est toi le
monsieur avec le pull ça va avec non non
et tu veux que dis il a raison le il va
aller très très bien le C avec ton pull
il a été fait pour toi jeanierre est-
que tu peux maintenant me donner un
chiffre
entre entre 1 et
11 3 3 c'est vous mademoiselle avec le
collier donc la finale
c'estentre je vais te demander
maintenant une lettre de
l'alphabet n'importe laquelle moi ou W W
quel est votre
prénom plus
[Applaudissements]
pr mon Jean-Pierre et on a hâte de te
voir à Miss France tu sais c'est pass
c'est la Semaine Prain tu sais que je
suis le seul gars qui regarde Miss
France que pour toi je m'en
fous je suis le seul gars au monde ça tu
faut que tu le saches voilà je
t'embrasse fort on t'aime tu nous
manques he je t'embrasse mon Jere
TBRE amour e les gars on tiens pas un
concept pas cher
là pas c'est vrai on tient pas un BA là
qui peut nous rapporter beaucoup d'os et
faire un deuxième complément d'enquête
les conneries tout
ça je
demande alors celui-là il va partir sur
Twitter ah bah oui regardz je peux faire
ça n'importe quoi la vache c'est
brillant c'est un vrai ah ouais c'est un
vrai hein il marque tout seul pour y
aller hein non mais c'est de la fausse
fourrure he aller bien sûr ou merci
merci et celui-là il va repartir sur
Twitter merci tu en voulais un ma chérie
bah avec plaisir he avec plaisir je
regarde regarde que je regarde ce que j'
bébé il y a un petit bébé
làbas ça te va lui là ah
a un petit souvenir de
toi letit pour mettre dans le camion le
petit làb pourett tu commces à
m'emder ser pour g pour un ser pour G
c'est la même famille a des cornes
ohouis
faire deux fois en 5 minutes c'est
insupportable les chériis il y a 240
millions d'euros à gagner à l'EUR
million j'ai joué j'ai joué ah j'ai pas
joué j'ai joué j'ai joué quel serait
indépendamment de cette somme votre
weekend de rêve si vous aviez un weekend
de rêve ce serait quoi avec 240 millions
on pe en faire 2 pas pour l'instant pour
l'instant contenti de ce que je te
donne content-oi de ce que je te donne
et tout ira très bien vre
weekend partir de ce soir faites ce que
vous voulez pendant tout le weekend et
vous venez lundi et vous fermez vos
gueules c'est pas compliqué alors votre
weekend de r je prends un jet privé
d'accord je mets les gens que j'aime
dedans on est dedans ou bien pas
tous tu choisis
lesqu
d'accord et ensuite on fait mais ensuite
on va dans dans des pays chauds là bien
sûr JS bah ouais avec un jet on traceou
mais c'est rapide on trace et on fait la
f il est très long on fait la fieste ou
bon c'est de la merde bien Jean-Michel
mer moi si c'est si j'ai assez je loue
un voot et je vais et je pars je vais
pêcher au
gros il dit t'emmerdes pas tu auras pas
assez euh t'emmerde pas t'emmerde pas
euh vous Pascal la tour du pint moi à
240 millions je
moi j'ai une fix les
2 question d'arent pourquoi une chance
sur 39 millions de gagner ah ouis bah
justement on sait jamais ben mtoi le cul
j'ar de gagner non non alors dis-moi ch
débarass weekend de r quoi vous est-ce
que si vous gagnez 240 millions vous
arrêtez tes PP
oui je termine la qui arrête t PM g je
termine même pas l'émission moi je
m'arrête en plein milieu si je rigol TER
franchement des r on
est00 pas tu termines la je suis vieux
quoi j'ai 62 ans bah tu termines la
saison quand même term la saison qui
arrê qui arrête à la fin de la
saison qui arrête à la fin de la saison
repose question arrête à la fin de la
saison tes PMP avec les 240 bares mais
toi tu vas t'arrêter
tout r non non mais les deux bah moi
j'arrête pour faire d'autres projets des
trucs je sais pas je prends un avion je
fais je fais des tour du monde des truc
çaanement vous êtes vraiment des RAR
mais fautit de ça montre la différence
entre quelqu'un qui aime son métier et
quelqu'un qui vient là pour 20 millions
vous continuez vous vous présentezm
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
lundi c'est que des hypocr mais non ils
ont tous des carrières à faire moi ça y
est je en cour fa ton weekend de rêve ah
moi je alors jet privé rempli de cavière
avec tous les potes et on se barre à
Tahiti parce que je suis fan de Tahiti
tu voir sûement kinv
là-bas des deux GG jet privé oui ça
c'est sûr Pr ou ou ou ouais pour aller
vite pourquoi on prend pas un A 330 pour
mettre vraiment tous les copains tu vois
tu es pas
limité problème on voit que Tu Vi de
chez BFM tu vois
petit petit et peut-être une virée dans
le désert genre le désert au Maroc et
tout ça dans dans une tente avec un un
énorme couscous avec plein d'amis
avec avec une méditation on parle pas
des 24
minutes se compris Patrick alors moi je
veux traverser c'est tout Paris avec une
voiture de police à toute vitesse pour
voir comment ça fait pas mal en grillant
tous les feux rouges à 100 km et tous
les passes droits ensuite je veux être
en immersion dans un club de Ligue 1 ou
Marseille ou Paris ou Monaco pour faire
vraiment le début du match dans le Vère
tout l'entrée des joueurs tout pareil le
coup d'en te le fais et je rejoins
gérardine après au Maroc pour manger du
couscous c'est bien
bien regarde qui vient de m'envoyer un
message au moment où
regardeeehe regarde deviné ben tu vois
mais montrez pas mon pas les garsis
c'est un truc de fou vous pouvez pas lui
faire vous savez il fait il prend la
place des enfants quand ils tiennent la
main comme
[Applaudissements]
ça ce que je vais faire j'ai envie j'ai
envie sais quoi j'ai envie de relancer
une émission on on on voilà on
RV ou géal génial magnifique ça c'est
très bien très très bien ça c'est génial
vous ce serait quoi vous h vous ce
serait quoi bonsoir euh bonsoir Patrick
euh je sais pas j'ai j'ai en Afrique pas
que tu sois venu toi tu couper ben alors
e tu as passé une tête oui ça va oui tu
es devenu tout timide toi bah non mais
qu'est-ce que tu
as arrête tu me
gênes mignonne oui elle est très
gentille ça va tu es contente d'être là
ou fait des très bonnes émissions bah
merci ah bon c'est pas moi qui si des
très
bon sors un peu je te jure un peu plus
non mais pas qure fois quand même onme
pas insable alors qu'est-ce que tu fais
toi je sais pas j' en Afrique c'est vrai
et ben vas-y tu peux y aller non oui non
oui j'irai
très bienah vas-y où en Afrique ton
cul non il y a plein d'endroits
tellement différents ple de pays
différents les animaux sauvages Safar
ouais c'est pas des animaux sauvages
quel ringar mais non mais le
Ken tu veux pas au Sénégal avec si avec
Fatou mais c'est très beau le Sénégal
aussi ah il para que tu éta à la soirée
ave Fatou il paraî que tu étais un cadar
on m'a dit il y a des potes qui étaaient
à la même soirée que toi je peux
dire tout frère c'est un canard
[Rires]
VC dire qui qui suiv derrière qui suiv
derrière frère il dit pas un
mot mais frère tu dis pas un mot frère
j' all parler elle est plus intéressante
que moi vouis Bernardo sur la tête de ma
mère il parle pas c'est gilberd qu'on
entend c'est un truc de ouf frère on m'a
dit hein je m'occupe d'elle t'occupe
d'elle ça veut dire quoi s'occuper
d'elle je vois si elle va bien si elle
veut boire quelque chose si elle ve
visiter le Sénat voilà B si elle est là
c'est pour m'occuper d'elle arrête de
faire le canard avec les meufs sinon
mais je te dis arrête de faire le canard
avec les meufs ça mais c'est bien aussi
d'être un peu élégant n' jamais marché
ça n'a jamais
marché arrêtez arrêtez je connais alors
comment on doit être
ex dire faut pas demander moi sur les
meufs je suis
nulah quand même weekend vous êtes bon
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait si si vous
avez un weekend de rêve moi si un
weekend de rêve franchement fais quo je
prends mon téléphone et je vous en
laisse tous de mon
répertoire ça c'est c'est faisable r
c'est quand même très c'est en un tu
vois déjà déjà déjà et qu'est-ce que tu
fais toi bah alors moi déjà je prends
bah je réserve pour aller dans le centre
intensif de kiné en Espagne mal ouais
c'est où en Espagne où ça c'est à s cou
Valy ah oua je connais costadel sol et
après j'emmène ma famille à New
York surtout pendant les il a des r
là pendant les périodes de Noël ouis
mais je te dis c'est en train d'êre là
il y a des rat partout à New York je
t'explique plus de r Paris fait les fra
il les RPP en
l'anglais
[Applaudissements]
rat américain c'est des rat américains
c'est les pires les rat r Merl
les r Merl les connais c'est pas la même
tête pour les rat français les ras
américainamécain le r
franais bon on se retrouve dans un
instant les chéris je la sens très bien
cette émission je la sens très bien même
les écureuils ils sont noirs ouais mais
ton cul aussi allez c'est parti
merci